Doutor, a creatina pode causar insônia?
Olha, essa pergunta sobre creatina,
insônia é um verdadeiro clássico aqui do
consultório. Não passa uma semana se
alguém me perguntar isso. E sabe o que
que é mais curioso? Literalmente semana
passada atendi uma paciente amácia super
disciplinada com os treinos, que chegou
no consultório jurando de pé junto que a
creatina estava acabando com o sono
dela. Doutor, desde que comecei a tomar
essa bendita creatina, não consigo
pregar no olho. E aí que a coisa fica
interessante, porque quando a gente vai
olhar o que a ciência mais atual tem
para dizer sobre isso e hora que acabou
de sair um estudo na National Geographic
em fevereiro de 2025, a história é
completamente diferente do que muita
gente pensa. Na real, a creatina pode
até melhorar o sono em algumas
situações. Pois é, você não leu errado.
Deixa eu explicar direitinho como é que
essa história funciona. A creatina,
gente, não é estimulante igual a
cafeína. Ela não mexe com o sistema
nervoso central, não te deixa ligadão
nem nada disso. O papel dela é bem
específico. Ela fica quietinha lá no
músculo, fornecendo energia rápida pra
contração muscular. É tipo uma bateria
extra pro seu celular. Não é um Red
Bull, é um power bank. O que acontece é
o seguinte, isso é fascinante. Tem um
estudo publicado na Scientific Reportes,
que mostrou que uma dose única de
creatina pode até melhorar o desempenho
cognitivo quando você tá privado de
sono. Os caras pegaram 15 pessoas,
deixaram eles acordados a noite toda,
fazendo testes mentais e quem tomou
creatina se saiu melhor. O efeito durou
até 9 horas. Então assim, se a creatina
fosse atrapalhar o sono, ela não ia
ajudar justamente quando você tá sem
dormir. Não concorda? Mas esa aí,
doutor, e a sua paciente Márcia, por que
que ela melhorou quando parou a
creatina? A que tá o pulo do gato.
Muitas vezes o que acontece é uma
coincidência temporal, sabe? A pessoa
começa a tomar creatina, começa a
treinar mais pesado, porque, né, com
creatina você aguenta mais o treino. Aí
treina às 8 horas da noite, chega em
casa todo bombado de endorfin,
adrenalina e não consegue dormir. O
culpado não é a creatina, é o horário do
treino. Tem também aquela história do
efeito psicossomático. A pessoa lê em
algum blog duvidoso que creatina tira o
sono, aí começa a tomar e fica
neurótica. Será que vou conseguir
dormir? E se eu ficar com insônia? E aí,
meu amigo, só de ficar pensando nisso já
perde sono mesmo. É tipo quando você tá
deitado na cama pensando, preciso
dormir, preciso dormir. Quanto mais
pensa, menos dorme. Outro detalhe
importante, muita gente mistura creatina
com pré-treino. Aí sim, meu caro, você
tá pedindo para não dormir. Pré-treino
geralmente tem cafeína para dar e
vender. Às vezes o equivalente a três ou
quatro cafezinhos. Toma isso às 7 horas
da noite e depois culpa a coitada da
creatina, não rola, né? A International
Society of Sports Nutrition, numa
revisão gigantesca com mais de 680
estudos, publicada agora em 2025, foi
categórica. A creatina é um dos
suplementos mais seguros estudados do
mundo. Não causa insônia, não prejudica
rins em pessoas saudáveis, não dá
calvice, não aumenta pressão. São tudo
mitos que a galera espalha por aí sem
base científica. E olha que
interessante, alguns pesquisadores da
Alemanha estão até estudando se a
creatina pode ser uma alternativa ao
café para quem precisa virar à noite
trabalhando ou estudando, porque ela
melhora a função cognitiva sem te deixar
agitado. É energia pro cérebro, mas sem
aquela tremedeira em ansiedade tão
típica do excesso de café. Agora,
voltando pra Márcia, sabe o que
descobrimos conversando? Ela tinha
começado a creatina junto com a mudança
no horário do treino. Ela passou a
malhar depois do trabalho lá pelas 8 da
noite. E mais, estava tomando um
pré-treino inocente, coitado, que a
amiga indicou que tinha mais café que um
bolo de café. Quando ela parou tudo de
uma vez, óbvio que dormiu melhor, mas
colocamos ela para tomar só creatina de
manhã, sem pré-treino. E adivinha?
Dormindo que nem bebê e com a
performance lá em cima nos treinos.
Então, resumindo a ópera, creatina
monoidratada pura não tira o seu sono.
Ponto. A ciência é clara nisso. Se você
tá com insônia tomar creatina, investiga
outras coisas. Horário do treino, usos
estimulantes, estresse do dia a dia,
aquela série na Netflix que você fica
maratonando é tarde, a lista de
suspeitos é grande, mas a creatina tá
livre dessa acusação. E para fechar com
chave de ouro, um estudo 2024 mostrou
que a suplementação creatina pode até
aumentar a duração do sono total em
algumas pessoas. Isso mesmo que você
ouviu. Tem gente dormindo mais e melhor
com creatina. Vai entender, né? O corpo
humano é mesmo uma caixinha de
surpresas. Então, se você tá em casa
preocupado se pode ou não pode tomar
creatina, fica tranquilo. Tome a sua
dose entre 3 a 4 g, pode ser até 5 g por
dia, de preferência com uma fonte de
carboidrato para melhorar a absorção em
qualquer horário que preferir. E se
tiver algum problema para dormir, olha
pro resto da sua rotina antes de ocupar
o pozinho branco. Combinado? Ah.